HOCKEY LINE SON.
BACK OF SIX
MATCHUPSPSDEFENSE.
THIS ONE WAS A PRETTY GOOD ONE.
>> Bob:
WRISTER FROM POO LYNN SHOT, HIM
NOT AFRAID TO MAKE CHANGES.
>> Steve: DETRTO GET THERE
FIRST.
GUENTZEL, LETANG, CROSBY, THE
DRIVE, THE REBOUND,
AND NAMESTNIKOV DIDN'T, IT
STAYS IN THE FOR GET OUT THERE
IT'S A SAVE RASMUSSEN
LARKIN TO PETTER SON.
PENSDETROIT RED WINGS WITH
A 2-1 LEMORE.
>> UNDERWAY, PERIOD LIKE HE'S N
JAKE GOES BERTUZZI.
CYCLES IT TOWILL TIP IN FOR
DETROIT.
DYLAN LAFOR A
PUSHES AND THEYEYAVAILABLE ALON
BOARDS.
FINDS ITS WAY
TALK
>> Steve: EVGENI RED WINGS.
ONE OF AT THE GLOVE!
AT JAKE CALVIN
PICKARD.
AND THE ALL.
>> Steve: THE TALENTED ROOKIE,
SHOOTOUT IN HIS CAREER.
RAYMOND ANGLES IN.
HE SCORES.
IT'S1-0 DETROIT AFWE'VE SEEN TH
FROM CROSBY.
YOU NEKNOW WHICH ONE E FOR CAPT
TH
PENGUINS NEEDING A GOAL